[Music]
Madagascar an island off the coast of
Africa it's one of the most biologically
diverse places in the world almost all
of its plants and animals aren't found
anywhere else on Earth and when we
looked at it from space we saw a spot a
massive Dark Circle almost perfectly
round over 13 km in diameter and big
enough that roads are diverted on either
side of it looking at it from the side
we you see it was a mountain and if you
zoomed all the way in you could see a
village nestled in the crater at its
center 8 km from the closest labeled
town on Google Maps isolated in a remote
part of a remote region of a
geographically isolated country it
looked like it could have been there for
Generations but if you looked backward
Through Time each year it gets smaller
and smaller and before 2008 there was no
one in there at all I wanted to try to
answer one
question why did these people move to
such an incredibly isolated
[Music]
place I was really starting from zero
here I didn't know anyone in Madagascar
I didn't know that much about Madagascar
but the question was could we get in
touch with the people living here just
by using the internet the closest
location tags were on the edges of the
mountain a butcher shop a playground and
a historical landmark but none of them
were real they all seem to be random
references to the popular Japanese Manga
and Anime series Attack on Titan written
in Russian the ones that did look real
churches hospitals and schools didn't
have much of a presence on the internet
so we looked at content that had been
geotagged nearby First on Twitter using
the coordinates of the village and a
search
radius until finally at 12 km away we
found someone a nonprofit worker who had
posted from a nearby Village in 2014 we
asked if he knew anything about the
village on the mountain but he never got
back to us on Instagram we looked for
pictures tagged in the nearest town
antana datra and found an aid
organization that had posted pictures
taken there we asked but they didn't
know they never actually been on the
Mountain at all and finally we looked at
geotags on YouTube and there was a video
geotags right next to the village on the
top of the mountain but
then it was just more Attack on Titan
stuff also written in Russian after a
while it felt like the internet alone
was not going to tell us very much so we
started reaching out to experts who had
worked in Madagascar experts in
[Music]
agriculture an experts in
biogeography I I don't know people
working in that region frankly it it's
in the middle of
nowhere Madagascar is a country of
almost 29 million people slightly more
than Australia slightly fewer than Texas
in majority of the country's population
over 60% lives in rural settings a lot
like this one but this Village was
particularly remote if you zoom out the
closest major city is a place called
sanded 18 km away with a population of
over 44,000 at this point in the process
it felt like we might need to take a
more drastic approach maybe we could
hire someone to make the journey up the
mountain to the Village itself someone
in
Madagascar
that's how we met L hi Christopher L
runs a production company in Madagascar
in the capital city of antana rivo she
was down to make the trip she started to
gather a crew make local contacts and
figure out how to get from antana rivo
all the way
here they weren't exactly sure yet how
they would get up to the Village or how
they'd establish contact once they got
there need the introduction to V from
someone is from the area yeah but they
knew they were going to have to do it in
just a few days in the middle of
Madagascar as's hot rainy season and
early one morning in January they
went is s she's going to be our
guide this is yes he an historian this
is W our fixer this is Jose I'm very
focused driver and and this is me you
know me
already as they approach the mountain
lii sent us messages every step of the
way
[Music]
so we finally found the crter it's just
down there and we are going to film
it until finally after traveling 10 km
by motorcycle and on foot they made it
to the top of the
mountain but when they got there and
were about to descend to the village in
the crater a massive storm appeared on
the
horizon and I had to turn
back they got extremely close but making
contact with the village would have to
wait until the end of the rainy season
which was in May 4 months
away still all the research we' done so
far gave us a detailed idea of what this
place looked like what L's team did see
looked green blush and clearly extremely
difficult to access but there was still
so much we didn't
know before L went in January she wasn't
convinced that anybody lived there at
all there's the small group of houses at
the very top in the very middle that
we've kind of been interested in it's
not possible to leave there and
especially because there's
earthquakes so I turned to some very
basic Googling and I found an article
about earthquakes in Madagascar the
article described how a team of
researchers mapped Madagascar via
seismic tomography that's tomography not
topography because it's mapping the
Earth's interior not exterior like a CT
scan for the planet all of these
measurements produced this final map of
the entire island with colors labeling
the different ages and kinds of Rock
and here in the center of the map I
could see one perfectly circular dot I
pulled it into Photoshop overlaid it
with the map and it lined up with the
mountain exactly according to the key
that meant that the mountain dated back
to the Cretaceous Period sometime
between 66 and 145 million years ago and
it was
volcanic this looked like a very very
extinct volcano but we wanted to know
for sure so I started looking for a
volcano expert from Madagascar who could
explain it to me and that led me to
salav ra harf it down he showed me a map
can you see it from a detailed
Geological Survey of the area that
circular structure is actually made of
rocks that form deep within the Earth
surface it has been dated using uranium
lead geochronology dating Techni
and is
actually 90 million years
old 90 million years old older than
Mount Everest the Grand Canyon vvus this
thing was ancient 90 million years meant
that this thing had been extinct for a
very very long time but that number was
significant for another reason that is
actually
overlapping on the India and Madagascar
separation okay uh salava was talking
about this moment right here when India
broke apart from Madagascar because
these rocks are 90 million years old it
makes sense that the volcano might have
something to do with this massive
separation of continents so we went
looking for experts who knew more about
the breakup of Madagascar in
India and we found Joe Mir a geology
Professor who's written a bunch about
the movement and formation of continents
this was a real crash course on volcanic
geology so I asked our motion designer
Matt to help me make this a little bit
easier to
follow Madagascar in India happened to
be located beneath this really
deep-seated mantle Source they're called
plumes when that plume reaches the
planet's crust it forms a hot spot as
Madagascar moved over in the hot spot it
burned a hole through Madagascar and
produced all the volcanics all over the
island as Madagascar's continental plate
continued to move those volcanoes were
eventually cut off from the hot spot and
without a heat Source they cooled and
collapsed and then you're left with the
plumbing system that was underneath that
volcano so that's what we were looking
at the collapsed remnants of a volcano
formed by a hotspot that had broken up
Madagascar in India at this point I had
no idea what any of this might have to
do with the village that we could see on
Google
Earth but right about then we heard back
from another malagi expert we'd emailed
he sent us a link to mindat.org this is
like the Wikipedia of min minals and
mines and it had a page about the
mountain including its name the ambo
hibi
massive finally we knew the name of this
mountain that had been unlabeled on
every other map we'd seen so far and we
could search for
it we found maps from 1899 1903 and 1916
where the amboi was always labeled as a
lush Forest the only one for almost 100
km that definitely didn't seem to be the
case anymore but maybe the these old
trees were a clue we kept looking and we
found old reports one from 1933 said
that at the highest part of the massive
there is a very open Valley called by
the indigenous andron nanga tiaka or
where we find fresh
water water maybe that's why the
villagers chose to move there the
Mountain's higher elevation meant that
it got more moisture feeding these
streams that flow down the mountain in
every direction and making the center a
perfect place for a village to
thrive then we tried to find reports
that were a little bit more recent and
on Google Scholar we found a 2012 paper
about the origins of the ambo hibbi it
covered everything from the geochemistry
to plate tectonics to microscopic images
of its rocks and it included Rock
samples taken right next to the crater
Village the paper was written by a South
African geoscientist named indivo
Cecilia MOSI and if she took Rock
samples from right here when the village
already looked like this she had to have
been in contact with the people living
there MOSI was busy doing field research
for the next few days so in the meantime
we dug deeper into her paper and it told
us what the formation actually was an
alkaline ring complex alkaline refers to
the chemistry of the magma it's the kind
of molten rock that appears when
continents break apart like Madagascar
and India did 90 million years ago I
took this new term and looked at dozens
more across the world
in Sudan Egypt ner Russia Namibia
Zimbabwe the United States they were
everywhere a whole planet covered in
circles the remnants of long extinct
volcanoes I wanted to talk to someone
who could tell me why a community of
people would want to live on top of an
alkaline ring complex so I went looking
for the most famous researcher of the
most famous alkaline ring complex out
there that's when this caught my eye
the reshot structure also called the eye
of the Sahara it's an alkaline ring
complex in morania surrounded by
conspiracy theories even on Google Maps
where it's littered with comments saying
that it's the site of Atlantis and that
nobody knows what it is but geologist
Michelle jaabra does know what it is
he's done tons of research there and
even helped get an illustration of it
onto martinous
currency
soil maybe that was why they moved here
this alkaline ring complex formed when
continents broke apart left behind a
valley with remarkably fertile soil
there was one last person who might know
something about the community living on
top of the ambo hibi complex indivo
Cecilia mukosi the geoscientist who had
studied it when she was back from doing
field research we
spoke I was first or second person to
map theab complex and try to understand
how it was formed it's it's quite
fertile and and so the area is good for
agriculture
one of the things that really caught us
in the first place about this location
was the fact that at the crater of the
Ring complex there is what looks like a
farm right right in the very middle do
you know what I'm talking about yeah you
sent me a a but there wasn't people
living on the center of the complex I
think this is this is quite recent and I
was there 15 15 10 years ago things
change after a
while I'd miss this the whole time
mosi's research was published in 2012
but she had actually visited the ambo
hiby 5 years earlier in
2007 before anyone had moved here in the
first
place so that was it we'd been trying to
learn about this incredibly remote
Village in an incredibly remote part of
the
country and the one person who would
formerly studied it most
recently had done so before the village
even
existed we had all this research and we
were
stumped but now the rainy season was
over and we finally had a chance to send
Loi and her crew to make the journey
again hi Christopher we are living now
so we are aging
to we are now on the way Loi brought a
whole new team including r andream
manise a filmmaker who captured scenes
as they drove through the Madagascar
Countryside of pineapple
vendors basket
Weavers and rice
Farmers we are 1 hour and 45 minutes
approximately from
tiid
candid the closest major city to the
ambo hibi
when they made it there they picked up
their final crew member Zohar a Ser
anded local who would be their guide
hello hello can you hear me now he told
me he'd climbed the ambo hiby many times
and even wrote his master's thesis on
its water resources but had never been
to the Village at its
[Music]
Center anandra just 8 km away from there
they could travel to interview view
people living on the outskirts of the
massive the crater Village's closest
neighbors the crew asked them what they
thought made this place
[Music]
special
they' met the people living closest to
the crater Village but climbing all the
way up the mountain would take a full
[Music]
day early the next
morning they set off for one last shot
at reaching the village what do you see
behind me there this line uh
there it's it's the
CR
[Music]
it's like in the middle of nowhere it's
a beautiful nowhere but
still until at last they
arrived so we are know approaching the
CR and they saw the village up close
full of dozens of houses livestock and
[Music]
people but as soon as they drove closer
things became tense some people in the
village think that we are a team of
spies comeing to take them guilty for
something so we are waiting for someone
to do this
citation we still need
to to
wait after 2 and 1/2 hours one of the
town's leaders came to talk we finally
succeed to find our
[Music]
facilitator
more specifically they migrated from
mandria a district in the region of
amoni Mania in the central Highlands of
Madagascar a journey of over 380
km like the majority of people in
amaroni Mania the ambah residents are
betso the third largest of Madagascar's
18 main ethnic groups meaning they
didn't just migrate to to a new home
they also became an ethnic minority now
living in a place where the marina
people are the
majority it still wasn't clear why they
chose this place in particular somewhere
so
remote until they sat down to interview
RZA fala one of The Village's
elders
[Music]
and they gave it a
name
amb amb or big island
[Music]
amboi so we had an answer about why they
lived here and why they traveled all
this way to live in a place like this it
was for the water and it was for the
soil but more than anything else it was
for space and it's easy to see why
in the entire District of sendi there
are about 49 people per square kilometer
but in the migrant's original home of
mon andriana that density is more than
twice as high and for Farmers like them
space to plant to breed livestock to
build a life is
everything and then the villagers took
Loi and the crew to see what they' done
with all of that
[Music]
space
a massive field of hundreds of lemon and
orange
[Music]
trees the Citrus are a cash crop fruits
grown for the purpose of selling at a
[Music]
market but to sell their produce at a
market they have to transport it down
the mountain to Anana datra the same
difficult Journey that Lai and her team
had just
[Music]
done
remoteness was the thing that first
fascinated us about this Village and it
was a central part of their story but it
was a story that stretched far beyond
this place Madagascar has some of the
least developed Road networks in the
world with just 5 km of Road per 100
square km of land the majority of
Madagascar's pop population lives in
rural areas a lot like this one but only
a tiny fraction of that rural population
lives within 2 km of a road that's
usable all year long which means that
almost 16 million people live
essentially unconnected having better
more connected roads means an easier
time accessing schools hospitals and
markets an easier time building a better
life hey hi Christopher how you doing
we've been to the CR
finally they live in a very very very
remote area because this is like the
center of the
crat and the way they live in the middle
of the crat and they can sustain
themselves it's it's amazing but to
access
there it's not an easy
life
when I was going through all the footage
L's team sent us after they made at home
I couldn't stop looking at this perfect
match to the first image we saw of the
village and it struck me apart from a
few photos taken with cameras hundreds
of kilometers up in the sky there's
basically no record of anos ambo be
anywhere on the internet until right
now with the internet we can look at
just about any part of the planet some
of the places we find might be made up
or might be surrounded by conspiracy
theories instead of
facts and some we can't learn much about
at all without showing up asking
questions and letting the people there
tell their
[Music]
story